[Music]
hello everyone
uh so we'll begin our discussion on the
chapter of stress uh
with the topic on traction
possibly at a point
okay so
the first thing that we're going to do
is again just like in
in the previous chapter on kinematics we
are going to consider a
three-dimensional body
okay so this is our general
three-dimensional body
now in the previous chapter on
kinematics we were not bothered at all
about the loadings that were taking
place on this general three-dimensional
body
but this time we will be uh for the
in order to keep the whole picture clear
i am not going
to represent the various loadings
that may be acting on this body
but you please understand that
there will be a certain distribution of
loads all over
this body okay now
uh under that under that loading
uh what we would like to focus on
is at a generic point somewhere inside
this body
okay so this is a general
three-dimensional body
and this is a point which is present
not on the surface of this general
three-dimensional body but rather inside
it
now uh
we want to expose this point the way we
can expose this point
is by uh making a plane
cut through this cut through this body
and passing through this
point now you can imagine
that there may be infinite number of
such place we are absolutely free to do
that
we can have this body
cut in this way in this way that way
anyway as long as it passes to this
point we are good
so uh so just as it as a specific
representation
so let us say that we are we are having
this kind of a plane
which is cutting through this body
and which is passing through this point
let's call this point p okay
now after if after i've chosen this
cutting plane
uh and it cuts through this uh it it
divides this entire three-dimensional
body into two regions
uh region one
and region two
all right what we are going to do is
consider this
region two so you understand that when
it cuts it
the cross section that will be exposed
will be somewhat like this
okay now
uh i want to consider this
region one
i want to consider this region 1 with
the point p
exposed in it so this is my region 1.
and you understand that this region 2
will be very much
present here
okay i i i am not concerned too much
with region 2 now
be something like this
[Music]
okay
now when i'm focusing on my region one
especially on this point p i consider
a little area around it
now you can understand that uh
since i have this various loadings
present inside
present on this uh on this body
when i cut out this region one
[Music]
a certain distribution of the loading
should still be present here
now in order for this entire part of the
body
or this entire region want to be in
static equilibrium
there must be a certain distribution of
forces acting all over this
exposed surface all over this entire
plane that has been
exposed by this by this cutting plane
however and this is very very important
i do not want to focus on the entire
distribution of forces that is present
here
rather i am going to focus my attention
singularly on the distribution of forces
on this small area
a so this is my area a and this is my
point b
so i want to focus
on this little area a so i'm drawing i'm
drawing it separately here
so this is my point b and this is my
area a
now you understand that on this area
a there will be a certain distribution
of forces
uh let me let me denote that
distribution of forces
like this
some generic distribution of forces
crisscrossing doesn't matter now you
have to understand
that that this distribution of forces
here
it only this distribution of forces
acting over the region a
that is not going to balance the the
forces which are present
over this outer surface it is the actual
distribution of forces all over this
entire plane that has been exposed by
the cutting plane
that is going to balance these things
okay however
for our purpose we are only concerned
with the distribution of forces that are
acting on this
area a now this is the most crucial
thing
which i believe has not been discussed
earlier and which are which we're
introducing afresh
uh in in mechanics of solids
so what i want to uh what i want to
what i want you to think is what will be
the statical
equivalent of this distribution of
forces so this is a concept that we
learned
in our first year mechanics the statical
equivalent of the distribution of forces
and the most generic
such statical equivalent will be a
single force
and a single couple so let me draw that
so
i'll redraw this little area a
so even though these two areas may be
looking different
i hope you can accept the fact that they
are they are just the same thing
okay so what i want to say is that
this entire distribution of forces will
be
equivalent to maybe
one force draw it a different way
uh maybe
one force acting like this
maybe like this
and one couple so this is
c and this is f
i'll put a vector over here
okay so this distribution of forces is
equivalent to this force
and this couple system they are
statically equivalent i hope you
remember
something about the statical equivalency
of the distribution of forces from your
question mechanics
all right now if after we have that what
we are going to do
is something very special and this is
where the importance of considering this
little area a will be
will be evident to you what we are going
to do now
is we are going to make this area a
to be very small we are going to shrink
it
so you can actually start this entire
process of
uh this entire thinking process back to
back from here
where you consider progressively smaller
and smaller areas around the point p
so you are kind of uh printing
the this little this little periphery
around the point
p so we are shrinking it here we are
shrinking it here so when we do that
what is going to happen
what is going to happen is this as you
shrink this area
naturally the distribution of forces
which you see here that is going to
change
has to because we are considering so if
you consider a smaller area here
the the forces that you will see there
will of course be different from what
you are seeing here which is a slightly
larger area
that is what i mean correspondingly
if you are considering a smaller area
with a certain different distribution of
forces
the statical equivalent of that will
also be different from what i have
depicted here okay so
if we keep on decreasing the area to
smaller and smaller regions
the statical equivalent of the force and
the couple is also
going to change but along with that
you understand that in the limiting case
that
a actually tends to zero okay when the
area becomes infinitesimally small
what is going to happen what is going to
happen is that
it is not only the area a which is going
to become very very small
but it is also the force which is
becoming infinitesimally small
because you have only a very very small
distribution of force
present around here so mind you that
our current situation is like this that
you have this
point p around which it is just a small
area even this is a very large area this
is not tending to zero but for the
purpose of clarity of drawing it
i am drawing it like this so we have the
point p and this area has shrunk to this
very very small region around the point
p
in this kind of situation our force
f has also tended to zero now what about
the couple
well the couple is also tending to zero
why
well you see the tuple is like is is
is found out by taking the cross product
between
a moment armando and a force so
uh when you so that kind of a
that kind of a moment arm would be
calculated
from some kind of a reference axis which
may be lying
on this region now if we are
decreasing the size of this region of of
this
of this area a the the length of that
moment arm is also decreasing is it not
so i repeat the way that this couple is
calculated
is effectively by calculating is by
taking the
uh the cross product of a moment
aromatic force
if we are decreasing the area
the moment arm size is also decreasing
in the limit that eight actually tends
to zero that momentum is basically going
to go to zero
and that is how the couple is going to
become zero
okay however you note one thing
that
suppose i ask you to think about this
ratio
the ratio
between the force vector
and the area what about that
well if you think about the magnitude
the
answer is not so straightforward because
area is tending to zero
the f is also tending to zero now what
really happens for the real answer here
is
that in the limit
that a tends to zero
even though f is becoming very very
small and a is also becoming very very
small
it's a ratio of two infinite symbols and
as you know from your studies of
fundamental studies of calculus
that this ratio of two infinite symbols
can be a finite number okay so this can
be
some finite value
despite the fact that individually a is
tending to zero and the magnitude
of f is tending to zero this ratio in
the limit that a tends to zero
it is going to some finite value and
this
is how the concept of traction is
defined
so we define traction
again we are using the symbol for
definition
by using a colon in front of an equal to
so this is
limit a tends to zero
affected by a now some of you might be
wondering
on the right hand side i have a vector
divided by scalar so
overall this should be a vector why have
i not put a vector
and that is actually a mistake there
should be actually a vector above it
so the the traction that we are saying
it is actually a traction vector
[Music]
so this is attraction vector sometimes
this is also referred to in some books
as stress vector
personally i'm not a big fan of this
particular terminology
stress vector so i will use this one
fraction vector okay so when i say this
concept of
traction across a plane at a point this
is what i mean
the limiting value of f by a
okay the limiting value of f vector by a
as a tends to zero
now you see there is a very very subtle
concept involved here
and that is all of this definition
it pertains to this very specific point
p
okay and not just that it
this particular definition is very very
much dependent
on the initial choice of your cutting
plane
instead of this kind of a cutting plane
that we have taken here
suppose we had a different sort of
orientation of our cutting plane
in that case the exposed
surface here would have been different
the region a that we would have
considered would have been different
the entire story would have been would
have been different as far as the values
are concerned
so the finite value that we would have
ended up with
had we chosen a different cutting plane
even if we had been sitting at the same
point
that value would have been different so
and certainly if you take a different
point
even if you choose the same cutting
cutting plane but choose a different
point certainly the value is going to be
different
and uh and even if you are sitting at
the same point this is very important
when you take a different cutting plane
the traction value is going to be
different so the traction is very much
dependent on two things
first the position itself and second the
orientation
of the cutting plane which is generating
it
so in other words what we can say
mathematically is that
the traction depends on the position
vector
of the point of concern it also depends
on the unit normal
of the plane which we are considering so
really what should what we should be
writing here is this
so instead of just this we should be
really writing
this as
t vector being a
function of the position vector of the
point p
so x vector denotes the position vector
of the point p
and the unit outward normal
to the plane that we are considering so
the unit outward normal
so you can think of it like this that
the unit outward normal here is
something like this this is the unit
outward normal okay
so this here is my
unit output normal
okay once you have chosen your cutting
plane the unit outward normal does not
change
even if you keep on shrinking or
enlarging your area
that is very very important the moment
you have you have decided on your
cutting plane
that uniquely determines your uh your
unit outward normal so you see here
this x defines the point the end defines
the
cutting plane okay so the definition of
traction vector
is uh is a very subtle concept and it is
uh it is the starting point of all our
subsequent discussions
of stresses now now we have been
discussing all of this in the context of
the region one
so what about the region two well it is
very simple
uh all that you think about is uh
just like these forces are you can
imagine that
uh you can understand very well that
these distribution of forces that are
present on the area a
that is actually exerted or brought
about due to the interaction with the
region 2 so it is actually the region 2
which is exerting this
these forces on the region 1 over the
area a
so whatever forces that we are seeing
here whatever thing we are writing here
that is
actually due to the interaction with the
region 2.
now just like the region two is exerting
forces on the region one
by newton's third law the region one is
of also giving or
is also exerting the same but opposite
oppositely directed kind of forces on
the region too
so if we were to consider the
the counterpart of point p which is part
of this region too
because note that this is just like a
like an imaginary cutting plane
there would be an exactly same story
that we could follow
uh by considering the region two however
there is one subtle difference and that
difference is
if you considered this region two what
about the unit outward normal
well i hope it will be immediately clear
to all of you
that the unit outward normal considering
this thing will be
minus n hat this should be perfectly
clear to everyone
so the moment you choose your cutting
plane this is n hat this is minus n
okay we are just saying that this is the
positive one this is just by convention
anyway so uh so
because we have this kind of a thing so
considering the region 2 and i'm just
not going to the next page because all
the diagrams are here
so considering
[Music]
region two what we have for the traction
vector
is first of all we are considering the
same point
p this is very very important we are
considering the same point p
it is like this p is part of this region
one that same p is also sitting there
okay it is like an imaginary plane so
you see if this picture should be
clearer
so this p is very much part of region
one it is also part of region two
there should not be any confusion about
it so this is the same
on the the position vector of the same
point p we are considering
however the unit outward normal
is the opposite one of what we had
considered here
okay now now we could go
into a into an in-depth discussion of
what i'm going to write next
but uh what i will just say is that uh
following uh basically basically
following newton's
third law what we can write is that this
is going to be the negative
is going to be the negative of the
traction vector
considering the region 1. so the
traction vector considering the same
point
p but sitting on the region 2 will be
the negative
of the traction vector considering the
same point p but
but within the region 1. so this concept
will be something which will be
subsequently be using in order to derive
some some very important
uh formula all right so with this we we
end the introductory
mathematical discussion uh of of stress
uh time and again we will be dealing
with uh
with this with this concept of traction
in fact everything will be built on this
and will continue with our discussions
in the next part of the lecture
thank you very much